new hotel property in the works near
legion stadium it's a whole new concept
combining a traditional hotel style with
a collaboration with an airbnb
sasha loftus joining us live in the area
with more on what those nearby have to
say hi sasha
hi there brian yes this is an empty lot
now but as you can see by this sign here
it's set to be a whole new type of
property here in las vegas now those we
spoke with tonight say they feel it's
really an opportunity for the future
another day another chance for las vegas
to grow everywhere you go they're
building something new this time it's
this spot at russell and decatur that
will soon turn into this
autonomous las vegas is advertised on
the ahc capitol holdings website as a
new type of hotel developed in
collaboration with airbnb the 303 room
property is just a few blocks away from
allegion stadium
and area businesses call this another
opportunity for an economic boost just
give me added
volume of business for us which is great
for the employees and staff brian
slipock owns jackson's bar and grill
right down the street he says events at
allegiant have upped foot traffic by
about 30 percent the last few years game
day things like that people come here
before people come here after the games
but he believes this kind of project
will bring another type of clientele not
only is there any construction people
that need to build it
but then after that when the people
coming into town staying there two three
four days as for those living in the
neighborhood they say it's hard to keep
up
with our city's ever changing skyline i
left last year
to california when i came back
all this area was built
now according to the ahc capital
holdings website they plan to start this
new hotel concept here in las vegas and
then add new properties all around the
world reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now